so I want to make sure that we don't
gloss over the the feminism part of this
because that's obviously where you spend
a lot of your your time you know I've
had many guests on this show and and
myself included that have been pretty
critical of third wave feminism how is
that sort of tied into everything we're
talking about now
well feminism has never been popular I
know now in retrospect we think oh no
second wave feminism was embraced it
wasn't Oh
first wave feminism the right to vote
was embraced it wasn't the suffragettes
back in the day were labeled terrorists
and in some ways they were I mean they
committed bombings in public buildings
over in England it has never been
popular in part because of the Marxist
elements in it in part just because
there has always been this thing it
happens in a lot of civil rights
movements but they they work and they
work and they work and it work and and
real lasting change takes a lot of time
it's not sexy and it's it doesn't feel
good and so at some point in every
movement you get this more militant wing
who gets tired of waiting and they they
blow something up either literally or
figuratively in the first wave it was
the the bombings of a monument in the
the second wave it was what I call the
the dwarfs ID and that the the feminist
sex wars continue to this day people
have this misconception that feminism is
a monolith it's not it's always had its
layers and it's its factions and there's
a lot of disagreement within it but what
sort of happened is the the sex negative
very reactive angry and I don't like
doing tone argument thanks for obvious
reasons but what I call the dork side
Andrea Dworkin and company they lost the
both the legal battle and the hearts and
minds battle in the mainstream /
pornography and so they backed
for a decade or two somewhat lick their
wounds a little and then hit these
subcultures or these pop culture areas
where we hadn't had this fight yet and
that's what we're dealing with right now
of the the fights that happened over
porn in the 70s moving into the 80s
we're now having about video games and
and you know pop-culture phenomenon
movies and the frustrating part is it's
not that there isn't a point somewhere
in there and it's not that we should we
shouldn't avoid discussing any topic
thinking something is stupid is not a
good enough reason not to have a
discussion about it right that's a
that's an intellectual shortcut the
problem is we can't have a discussion
because everything is I got so angry I
made a sign right it's two people it's
two groups
hopefully just two groups usually more
than that shouting past each other as
opposed to sitting down and having a
conversation and we could get into the
structural reasons for that but that is
a deep dive yeah so when you talk about
it going from the 70's and the
demonization of porn and how it shifted
into video games and a lot of the same
arguments can be made about how they you
know demonized violence violent movies
probably you know in the 70s in the 90s
right and then we shifted we shifted it
to Mortal Kombat in the 90s but on the
on the female front you know like when I
was playing Mortal not Mortal Kombat
when I was playing Grand Theft Auto on
PlayStation and you could just grab and
I never really played to accomplish
anything I just was driving into things
and blowing things up and whatever and I
never got very far in the game but I had
fun when you could grab someone out of
the car and punch them or whatever I
could I could see a woman watching out
and say wait a minute you're grabbing a
woman out of the car punching her in the
face and stealing her car
that's an T woman I can understand why
they would say that but to me that would
be very misguided because the I never
did it like I was hunting down a woman I
treated a woman the exact way I would
treat a man in the video game world
which is I grabbed them out of their car
and I punched them so III think you're
with me on that in terms of that you
would want a quality you would want
women to be treated the same way in a
game right my big wish for the Grand
Theft Auto series that Rockstar just
starts giving the prostitutes weapons
because that solves all the problems I
mean the problem right now is I think
it's too easy to kill these women that
you've just obtained the services are
for your own benefit in Grand Theft Auto
a police officer will have a gun they
can shoot back the prostitutes for
whatever reason in this very dangerous
city don't have tasers don't have guns
don't have pepper spray that's the real
issue with it not it's making them
artificially helpless in a world where
it doesn't make sense not so much
you can punch a woman in the face
because I don't have issues with that
because if you know you look at the real
world women are fighting to get
frontline combat in the Armed Services
full status and the police mixed martial
arts you know UFC women
punch and kick each other in the face
for a living there it we're getting into
this benevolent sexism territory that is
still very little understood and this
idea that oh we think it's great that we
should hold us all to a higher conduct
standard when it comes to women but it's
really not because you can't see someone
as a victim and a leader at the same
time and all these arguments all these
debates this wringing of hands and
clutching at pearls against why aren't
there more women leaders well that's why
because if we continue to think that
women need protection from ideas and
words in a world that is very
technologically driven and gadgets solve
a lot of the physical imbalances that
made this an issue in the past and make
chivalry a thing right
we cannot be treated in the same
standard as a male CEO or a male
political leader or you know even a male
villain if we're seen as this thing
inherently need of protection it just it
can't work it's it's sheering it's it's
crossing the streams yeah right yeah
that's a that's a Ghostbusters reference
right that's a Ghostbusters it's a bad
metaphor
unfortunately because crossing the
streams is actually good at the end but
you know we we ended up having to fight
a giant marshmallow monster and that's a
really unfortunate joke if you think
about it somewhere in this context so
let's not go there
yeah I see what you did there though as
you saying this it reminds me so I'm
curious when did you see Mad Max fury
road uh-huh so I absolutely loved it
just I thought it was probably the best
action movie in like 30 years and when I
walked out of there I thought it was
just great and then I heard somebody say
in the theater as we walked out about
how you know Charlize Theron is really
the the hero of the story and all that
and I hadn't even thought about it that
way I thought she you know she was a
good guy in Mad Max was a good guy and
they did their thing but I would suspect
that she probably although the way
you're nodding your head maybe you're
not gonna agree with me that she really
is sort of the perfect in that that
character as a woman is probably the
perfect female character for a movie
right because she was badass she you
know she used Mad Max to hold the gun at
that great moment you know instead of
him using her to shoot she used him that
he and that she was a boss and in charge
of saving all these people that she
really was sort of the the perfect
female character in in that it was full
and unapologetic and all that I mean it
was a great the movie was fun right it
was a two-hour car chase and I think
people have made altogether too much of
this film there were elements about it
that you could say we're exceptionally
feminists there were other elements of
it where it's like you know just because
girls are punching patriarchy are
running it over with the cars doesn't
make it a feminist film there's still a
lot of beauty standard tied into some
really difficult stuff and I don't use
the word problematic I can't stand it so
you know the idea that they're all out
in the desert in this society where
resources are are scarce and
all fairly pale skinned white people
give me a break that race would have
adapted to that environment more so
we're still dealing with the beauty myth
a lot you know the Western Beauty myth
but that's overthinking it it's it's a
two-hour car chase if we start adding
that then we have to wonder what the
deal is with that guy playing the guitar
in long underwear you know yeah yeah
exactly you know for those about to rock
put on the long johns I just wanted to
see the back of him to see me on that
butt flap but and that's the thing
there's an element of displacement in
fantasy that you you can't ignore when
you do this sort of analysis at some
point it's just fun there was a
pre-existing tradition with the
aesthetic of Mad Max that they didn't
want to dismantle too much and I was
fine with that your comment on the
perfect female character this gets into
the question of is there any such thing
of a perfect female character because if
you say that Charlize Theron as the
grease covered one-armed you know bad
ass is the perfect female character then
somebody like say the main character of
the movie enchanted who's sort of this
princess with attitude who makes dresses
out of curtains and you know she's got
her own kind of cute agency you're
saying she's imperfect and then you get
into this idea of there being one right
kind of woman at any given time that's
when I start that's when I start going
and I think that's what you got out of
my reaction cuz I'm like we're gonna get
into this perfect archetype we're gonna
get into this Platonic ideal of
womanhood and no matter what no matter
what the ideal is in any given time as
long as there is a single idea ideal
then we've got problems because
everybody who doesn't conform to that
ideal is obviously not ideal and the
problem with superhero films and things
like that is you've got you got Tony
Stark and you've got Captain America and
you got Falcon and you got four and
you've got you know Bruce Banner who is
very different from the Hulk
you got all these different types of
dudes to choose from you've got Scarlett
Johansson and I came out pretty well in
terms of perfect woman in the Avengers
because of the physical resemblance but
what about people who don't look that
way there's nothing to represent them in
those films and that's when we get into
these issues of inclusion and it's a
very deep well and so I will agree with
you that
furiosa is a great character I
personally like the old lady's great
they they were we need more of that and
we need to bring back the Crone as a
legitimate archetype we need more badass
golden girls cuz now you're speaking my
language really yeah but you know
there's a classic example of a bunch of
women talking to each other about stuff
that was important to women at that age
and they didn't think that the Golden
Girls was going to appeal to that young
audience but people love them because
they had universal problems right and
the chrome cuz you've got those three
sort of fairytale archetypes the maid in
the matriarch in the chrome and the way
they interplay in fairy tales is very
interesting but over the years as we've
become more and more and more youth
obsessed we've gotten the maiden we've
gotten the matriarch and sort of the
Alice in Wonderland thing we've lost the
crown and you know epic fantasy and
video games keeps them there
thank goodness games like you know The
Witcher series and Dragon Age keep very
powerful chrome characters involved but
it's an important part of the life cycle
that we've lost and if you want to look
at Mad Max from a feminist perspective
like it's cool that they had different
types of badass women instead of it all
having to be embodied in one and yes
very oh so was the the leader and it was
this whole thing if she was sort of left
in charge and then he walks away and I
didn't catch that at first cuz I go
that's one Mad Max always does right
yeah yeah I'm looking at it like no this
is the this is the this is a Mad Max
movie these things have to happen
but when you actually think about it I
mean if you look at a movie like with
the Thunderdome Tina Turner was the big
WOW there you know and this idea of Mad
Max not really being the center of
attention is not new I think it's just
been so long and I think that when those
films came out there were a lot more
women in those aggressive very forward
very rock and roll like guar and the
desert kind of thing that we didn't stop
and think about it so much
now because we're living in the princess
generation with the pink section in the
toy store and The Hunger Games where
we're designer clothes and then fight
all of a sudden it's an awakening all
over again you know we're sort of
getting our groove back in that regard
and and this is why history is so
important and unfortunately in our
educational paradigm we don't have the
benefit of historical context we think
this is all new but to go Battlestar
Galactica this has all happened before
this will all happen again oh man you're
busting out all my favorite references
here Thunder God Battlestar Golden Girls
holy cow alright so let's shift slightly
here although this is all kind of
ancillary related
let's talk about cyberbullying for a
little bit because it's packaged in
online life and some of the feminist
stuff you're talking about how real do
you think it is because um I've become
on the side that just for the most part
for the most part and I know sometimes
it translates into real world stuff but
for the most part it just doesn't matter
well what we discuss as cyberbullying is
not in fact cyberbullying we see this
one tweet that people find offensive and
then we see it as cyberbullying right
that's not what it is it's a pattern of
behavior and there there was a group on
the internet some chat logs got leaked
that was trying to make me kill myself
like actively trying to make me take my
own life that is cyberbullying they were
unsuccessful and
was dumb but the intent was to make
something bad happen so the problem is
when you get into real on the Internet
real is how much how much of yourself
you put into that online environment
right so I think maybe that's where I
should have led with the question
instead of dismissing it seriously
because I wanted to get to that but I
guess I was really talk about the online
part versus the real part so I'm glad
you're making the right entry there so
what happens with with true
cyberbullying is you get you get pulled
into this world people become
marginalized from reality and it's its
most significant with teenagers because
teenagers are still forming their
personal boundaries right you the reason
things are 18-plus and if you want to go
true human development you have to push
it up to 20 to 23 years old people are
not fully formed human beings yet and
they're getting into these online
environments where it's very tough to
tell what's real that's the brilliance
of mr. robot is it it it immerses you in
that subjective reality of the Internet
in a television show but these young
people and some older people who because
of abuse or because of various things
don't have strong personal boundaries
they have their own sense of self
removed it is artificially removed from
them and they start doing things and
saying things they know are wrong out of
fear and power dynamics are very
interesting on the internet because
something as simple as anonymity can
make a person who is powerless be much
more powerful when you don't know where
something's coming from right when
someone is tape is posting a picture of
your house the front of your house
online and you don't know where it's
coming from that can be very very scary
right so that's where I would make the
distinction and that's the the real
world dysfunction that you're talking
about I'm not diminishing of course
daxing people and actual real-world
violence that could come of this you
know letting people know other locations
or any of that kind of stuff or personal
financial information that kind of stuff
I was talking with so those are the two
pieces of this there's that
but I mean that that is not the real
world you know somebody taking a Google
Earth picture of some of your house and
putting it online that's not the real
world
that's real ish you know you get into
this truthiness that is the world
filtered through the internet someone is
not standing outside your house taking a
picture someone found your address
through something mm-hmm and and and so
they connect to the dots
they went I'm gonna grab this from this
broadcast where somebody happened to
leave the Geo tag on I'm gonna look this
up I'm gonna grab the Google Earth image
and make it seem like I'm standing right
outside your house the emotional
response is real real yeah but it's not
real and that's are we talking about the
emotions real are we talking about the
threat being real that is a very very
difficult thing but unfortunately our
various laws in various jurisdictions
are really lagging behind yeah so how
have you dealt with this I mean as
someone that puts yourself out there
you're totally you're not afraid to
share your opinions and all that
everything that you're saying here I
know he's gonna obviously bring a
certain amount of 8 I'll get a certain
amount of hate just for talking to you
about it how do you navigate that in
your own life well first of all there's
very little of me to Doc's including
there's so many pictures of my ass on
the internet it's not even funny so
there's very little that can embarrass
me but that was part of where my
strategies that I worked with a national
youth organization up in up here in
Canada to adopt best practices for
insulating and dealing with
cyberbullying and what you have to do is
recognize that it's a negative ad
campaign it's more like the nonsense
that goes on in politics than real life
stalking or real life bullying and
obviously negative ad campaign sounds a
lot less scary than cyberbullying right
but precisely the first step is to take
the fear out of it and help the person
get a sense of control back because once
you get that sense of control back once
you reassert those personal boundaries
then it becomes noise right and that's
the difference between somebody who is
resilient to it and someone who is not
and that is what we do I use the the the
six powers of persuasion you know the
six weapons of influence sort of thing
and I break it down for youth showing
that this is a this is a negative ad
campaign that's all it is if you are at
you know physical risk from anybody but
yourself
this goes to another level now this is
not something that community and solved
then it's a legal issue you know then
it's an issue for the police however
most of it sits in this gray area below
what is appropriate and acceptable and
above what is illegal and that's the
stuff that we have to work on together
and the thing people don't do they don't
tend to do is talk to the people around
them and before it starts and say what
do we do if this happens and this is
something I would really suggest that
that families do that parents do that
significant others do anybody who spends
any kind of time in Internet communities
get a plan in advance because
consistency is a power of persuasion
what cyberbullying attempts to do is
force you to try to be consistent in
inconsistent way so it usually takes
your biggest strength whether that be
honesty or openness of transparency and
turn it into a negative call you a liar
say you're hiding something whatever and
so you do more and more and more you put
more and more and more effort into
trying to keep yourself consistent and
that's what wears you out
that's what exhausts you and leads you
to despair and all that stuff you end up
fighting it well if you've got a plan
with you you're with your social group
with your you know your support support
staff for lack of a better term in
advance then instead of it like what do
i do what do i do then it's okay
protocols kick in this is what we do
this is what we've agreed to do and so I
suggest that people write down the steps
and sign it because again it's an opt-in
in advance and that's what a lot of
people don't do and that's why the first
time
happens is often the worst yeah it's so
interesting because what you're talking
about can be related to so many it's not
just people in the gaming community or
in any of the things that we've talked
about here I see this so you know I see
this so much with the tactics that I'm
always talking about that the regressive
left uses about lying and smearing and
slandering people and making people
defend things over and over and you know
fake memes and misquoted things and all
of this stuff and it's like yeah if if
those of us that that were to be brave
enough to put on popular positions out
there really had a plan to deal with the
backlash that would save us from a lot
of mental energy that we have to spend
cleaning up messes that aren't of our
own doing yeah cuz it takes a lot less
energy to execute them to build right
and you can do it from a place of calm
and a place of an even keel before it
happens I mean the regressive left
thinks I'm literally the devil their
words not mine
and there's a reason for that it's
because I have developed these things
that actually do work and so you know I
I went through that period where the the
regressives in my field did almost make
me quit and I I wrote about it
extensively and hit the point where it's
like okay either I'm gonna quit or I'm
gonna get serious about this and
actually develop a plan make something
good come out of this that other people
can replicate because if I've done the
work
why shouldn't society benefit and and
isn't that what progressive values are
like that right there let's prevent the
same mistakes let's make progress are
you saying aggressives aren't really for
progress Dave I remember when we used to
be called liberals and the liberal
became a dirty word and so they adopted
progressives as a euphemism for liberal
and now progressives have become a dirty
word and it it's precisely this sort of
Orwellian you know doublethink word play
that has always been sort of you know
the the phrase that must not be named is
cultural Marxism it's funny because it's
almost the serpent eating its own tail
at this point they call it political
correctness it's just a way of making
people burn a lot of energy on things
that don't matter so we don't address
the things that really do yeah
well listen Liana there's so much more
that I wanted to do here but this is
what we're gonna do next time we'll have
you on again we're gonna do it in person
but you are going to get me all cosplay
DUP do that does that sound doable
that is yay I'm so excited yeah and it's
gonna be Jedi
it's gonna be Star Wars related but like
you know could be off a little bit you
know I mean so we're gonna do like
original character we're gonna do like
like your first name's Reuben and then
we need like a one syllable last name
for your like original Jedi character oh
right right all right well well you know
we'll deal with that are you gonna be
are you gonna be human are you gonna be
one of the like alien races
I think alien but I don't want to give
this all the way to everybody right now
we got a little excited we got to leave
them wanting more
all right well really Leon it was it was
a pleasure talking to you and you guys
can follow Liana it is a treadley on a
ke on the twitter or check out her site
at Liana Kerzner com
you